[Musique]
Véronique prince Michel David Michel
soget bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir la
mairesse de Saint-Urbain Cana vu
d'autres là qui est en politique
municipale depuis très très longtemps
en raison de souligner le travail
extraordinaire des pompiers volontaires
qui sont les premiers répondants dans
beaucoup beaucoup d'avoir les pompiers
sont les premiers répondants les
pompiers volontaires dans beaucoup de
municipalités le son et
Michel c'est peut-être un petit
commentaire là-dessus sur l'important
c'est vrai qui ont d'autres métiers là
je veux dire ils font pas ça à temps
plein
puis on oublie que dans toutes les
petites municipalités du Québec c'est
très rare qu'un corps de pompier comme
il y en a une ville
c'est des gens qui bon ils sont
entraînés mais ils sont entraînés et ils
sont les premiers répondants puis donc
ils prennent des risques là
ça sent mal parti qui ont donné leur vie
qui veut dire c'est c'est ce risque là
que des gens dans toutes les
municipalités du Québec accepte
volontairement pour aider leurs
concitoyens c'est remarquable on a une
chance de dire
et c'est la vertu peut-être la plus la
plus importante de toute Michel David le
courage c'est des gens courageux
absolument et on se rend pas compte
c'est vrai surtout quand on vit dans les
grands centres et où on a toutes sortes
d'organismes officiels je peux dire à
notre disposition
d'appeler le 91 là quand vous êtes pris
très loin il faut pas espérer que ça
réagisse rapidement alors oui écoutez
c'est tout à fait admirable oui
Véronique c'est touchant à la comment
elle a les connaît elle connaît bien les
la famille c'est une petite communauté
tu sais serrée où ils ont pris un tout
terrain sont allés on va aller aider ce
couple là qui finalement a été héliporté
plus tard oui puis j'ai bien aimé la
façon dont tu es là valorisée justement
leur travail puis le fait que
c'est malheureusement une exception là
parce qu'on a beaucoup des pompiers
volontaires au Québec faut pas que les
gens cessent de le devenir
malheureusement pour des choses qui se
passent comme ça des tragédies comme
celle-là mais je trouve que très bien
valorisé le travail de ces deux
personnes là je vous fais écouter par
ailleurs parce que la question qui se
pose de façon encore plus
urgente depuis aujourd'hui qui va payer
pour tout ça pour les adaptation les
municipalités demandent 2 milliards de
plus il se réunissent demain je fais
entendre monsieur Legault un échange
avec Gabriel ado Dubois madame plante on
revient tout de suite
faut savoir déjà quand on additionne
tous les programmes des différents
ministères il y a déjà un virgule deux
milliards qui est disponible pour les
municipalités pour l'adaptation au
changement climatique c'est un partage
de responsabilité entre les
municipalités faut comprendre là les
municipalités se finance avec des taxes
foncières le gouvernement du Québec
finance essentiellement que des impôts
sur le revenu puis les taxes de vente
puis je rappelle que le gouvernement du
Québec là déjà nos impôts sur le revenu
sont plus élevés que le niveau de nos
voisins donc c'est pas illimité
nous ce qu'on dit c'est quand qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour
les on s'évan se répéter alors si vous
me demandez ce que le gouvernement fait
assez la réponse est non mais ce qui est
positif c'est qu'avec l'UMQ on a un
rapport puis on sait que sur quoi on
doit travailler
est-ce que le premier ministre va
répondre présent pour les mères et les
maires qui sont en première ligne des
changements climatiques
je reconnais Québec solidaire on dit
qu'on a déjà annoncé 1,2 milliards qu'on
va annoncer un plan dictionnel d'un
virgule 4 milliards puisque nous dit que
soldat c'est qu'il faudra augmenter les
taxes donc mettre des taxes orange
additionnelles madame madame la
Présidente je pense qu'on doit
partager ce défi avec les municipalités
Véronique
au Québec solidaire oui mais les
municipalités aussi qui reviennent à la
charge oui mais je pense qu'il y a des
arguments valables des deux côtés parce
que quand vous regardez ça comparatif
vous avez les villes qui demandent
essentiellement si on regarde la même
base là sur 5 ans ce que les
municipalités demandent ces 10 milliards
sur 5 ans ce que le gouvernement est
prêt à donner sur cinq ans ces deux
points 6 milliards c'est sûr que quand
on regarde ça on dit oh le gouvernement
est vraiment pas prendre en mettre
beaucoup mais ces arguments c'est il y a
pas de ventilation de ce que les
municipalités demandent donc est-ce que
c'est un montant basé sur une étude qui
pourrait devenir un peu un fourre-tout
puis on va aller grappiller de l'argent
là-dedans et tout ça ce que le
gouvernement aimerait avoir c'est
davantage une liste précise de projets
municipalités par municipalité justement
pour lutter et s'adapter au changement
climatique donc il y a quand même des
arguments valables de son côté en disant
parce que si on fait pas cette
ventilation là mais il y a une limite à
la capacité de payer des contribuables
de l'autre côté vous avez les
municipalité qui disent oui mais on peut
pas tout prévoir on en a des projets
qu'on est capable de vous donner mais on
peut pas prévoir qu'il va y avoir cette
inondation là ou cette tempête de vergla
donc en même temps ça nous en prend un
quand même un fond d'urgence alors
c'est normal que de leur côté veulent
avoir ce coussin là mais le gouvernement
dit ben à ce moment-là nous on a plein
de programmes des programmes en
environnement en affaires municipale des
programmes de toutes sortes en transport
aller chercher l'argent dans les
différents programmes c'est pas toujours
simple non plus d'aller chercher
l'argent dans chacun des programmes donc
c'est pour ça que je dis le gouvernement
paraît moins bien parce qu'on dirait
qu'il veut pas donner l'argent avec les
municipalités veulent avoir mais les
arguments de deux côtés
avec le fédéral c'est que c'est on
gratte un peu c'est plus et Monsieur
LEGO a dit aujourd'hui c'est le même
payeur de taxes
Michel David n'empêche si tu ne
discussion appelons ça comme ça qui va
prendre de l'ampleur
ah évidemment écoutez je pense que les
mots qu'on entend le plus depuis
quelques jours c'est du jamais vu alors
on sait que le jamais vu va se
reproduire ce qu'on sait pas c'est
quelle ampleur ça va prendre parce que
là il y a des endroits où on n'avait
jamais pensé que ça pourrait arriver qui
tout d'un coup se retrouve au milieu là
d'une véritable catastrophe alors si on
sait pas ce qui va arriver on sait pas
ce que ça va coûter et à un moment donné
on se dit c'est pas possible de payer je
vous donne l'exemple il y a quelques
semaines la tempête de verglas tout le
monde sait comment ça dire faut enterrer
les fils ça a plus de bon sang puis là
tout de suite l'évaluation je sais pas
sur quelle base elle est exactement
faite là mais en gros on a dit ça va
coûter 100 milliards alors on peut pas
imaginer que tout d'un coup on peut
trouver 100 milliards là pour pour
enterrer ça pendant quelques années puis
ça va être la même chose je crains dans
le cas des des conséquences des méfaits
des changements climatiques au cours des
prochaines années ça va s'additionner
les milliards alors à un moment donné
on pourra pas même avec la meilleure
volonté du monde répondre à la demande
oui Michel c'est parce que la demande
peut être infinie aussi comme dit
Véronique le gouvernement parce que
maintenant le gouvernement veut des
plans plus détaillés pour les projets de
l'ironie je ferme la parenthèse mais
Michel C donc le gouvernement dit on
peut pas non plus envoyer des milliards
municipalités comme ça
non c'est vrai mais il y a une chose qui
est même monsieur
financent avec la taxe foncière la taxe
foncière et pas un instrument très
performant pour les municipalités à la
fin ça donne des services à la propriété
mais on leur a ajouté toutes sortes les
bibliothèques municipales de transport a
quand même été ça alors les
municipalités disent depuis moi je pense
que 45
les municipalités disent pour revoir la
fiscalité municipale on ne peut plus
avec l'instrument imparfait qui est la
taxe foncière régler tout et là des
catastrophes comme celle-là on a eu
Michel ledi ça va devenir plus fréquent
on le sait on sait pas quand ça va
frapper mais on sait que ça va frapper
plus souvent alors il faut revoir la
fiscalité municipale c'est dire à ce
partenariat pour faire ça en
collaboration vous allez en payer un
bout
si municipalités sont capables d'en
payer un bout parce que c'est pas elle
qu'ils ont un gros pouce qui ont
non on peut pas augmenter les taxes
foncières il y a un poisson qui arrive
vite mais très bien mais quand Monsieur
le goût dit il a raison peu importe la
taxe la forme qui l'aperçoit ça vient
toute la même place et il y a une limite
à augmenter le fardeau fiscal alors ce
que les municipalités pourraient aller
chercher comme revenu additionnel peu
importe la façon dont on va le faire il
va falloir que quelqu'un renonce à ses
revenus là et le gouvernement est
certainement pas prêt à le faire pour le
moment en tout cas très bien
il y a une rencontre actuellement qui
vient de prendre fin le dicton avec les
chefs syndicaux on va entendre monsieur
Legault on lui a posé la question parce
que les grandes manoeuvres
l'ostéopédéral là ça s'accélère de votre
côté Véronique sur le goût qui dit
vouloir régler on le comprend on écoute
ce qu'on veut c'est de régler le plus
vite possible pour le bien de la
population québécoise mais aussi pour le
bien des travailleurs donc moi je pense
que c'est un avantage des deux parties
de s'entendre le plus rapidement
possible puis je rappelle que notre
offre couve l'inflation sur la période
de l'offre de 4 ans
rencontre je pense qu'on vient d'avoir
une photo d'ailleurs de cette rencontre
au sommet avec monsieur Legault qui a
voulu peut-être adoucir certaines
impressions on se souvient avec la fille
qui a quelques semaines à là je peux pas
lire mais on voit la on voit la
rencontre je vais me rapprocher j'ai
rencontré aujourd'hui les dirigeants
syndicaux FTQ CSN on le voit avec Magali
Picard Eric gingrad Caroline Senneville
et Robert Comeau je crois alors c'est un
gros défi Michel David qui s'en vient
ce sont de grosses négociations compte
tenues de la réforme en santé qu'on veut
faire et en éducation également oui
c'est des grosses négociations c'est des
gros chiffres bon là j'entendais les 113
syndicales ce que vous avez octroyé
scottawa octroyer elle a fonctionnaire
c'est beaucoup trop peu pour nous et
c'était quand même
de l'ordre de quoi 12 12% sur une
période de 3 ans
on n'est pas là-dedans on demande autour
de 21 % du côté du Québec alors je vois
pas pour le moment le comment ça
pourrait se rapprocher mais mais je
comprends parfaitement les centrales
parce que quand on regarde les chiffres
par exemple de l'Institut de la
statistique du Québec
les travailleurs du secteur public sont
très très loin en termes de rémunération
globale même si on inclut tout de ce que
perçoivent à peu près tout le monde qui
est syndiqué au Québec que ça soit les
les fonctionnaires municipaux et
fonctionnaires
fédéraux dans université les grandes
entreprises tout le monde gagne plus
alors je comprends parfaitement que ce
coffre le gouvernement est perçu comme
trop peu on va écouter quelques secondes
si vous voulez bien c'est ça ils sont à
la sortie du bureau du premier ministre
on va écouter voir le ton travail à la
fin avenant le cas il y a pas d'entente
on va voir les travailleurs
on soumet l'État et où on est rendu ce
qu'on a de sur la table notre objectif
est d'avoir un contrat négocié avec le
gouvernement vous savez qu'au niveau des
services publics au Québec actuellement
les travailleurs les travailleurs
partout dans le réseau que ce soit dans
le réseau scolaire à la santé que ça
soit nos gens au niveau des services
sociaux sont épuisés donc par respect
pour tout ce monde-là on va s'assurer de
rester à la table tant aussi longtemps
qu'on est capable d'avoir des avancées
vous a donné des signes encourageants
d'ouverture dans négociations vous êtes
prêts à l'échelle du lest que vous êtes
prêt maintenant écarter la menace de
grêle on n'a pas avec Monsieur Lego je
vais mettre au clair on a pas négocié
avec monsieur Legault c'est pas le but
on a des responsables à négociation
autant de notre côté que du côté du
gouvernement du Québec ce qui est clair
c'est que le gouvernement logo le
Premier ministre nous a fait comprendre
que lui son souhait c'est d'avoir une
convention collective des conventions
collectives signées là ou plutôt que le
mois de juin alors écoutez on a aucun
problème avec cette avenue là tant mieux
on est capable d'assumer ça puis
d'encourager ça mais pour ça ça prend
des signaux et c'est ce qu'on va voir
dans les prochaines semaines à la
négociation
ça aide toujours vers un express des
rencontres sur elle est toujours ça
dépend mais la plupart du temps sur le
gars a voulu dire garder on va allons-y
de bonne foi des deux côtés bien sûr de
régler ça au plus vite là oui c'est sûr
que parfois ça permet de tempérer un
petit peu les choses là mais le
gouvernement le goût est quand même
pressé effectivement de signer cette
convention collective là parce que la
réforme en santé Christian Dubé va
dépendre beaucoup des négociations de
Sonia Lebel alors s'il veut pouvoir
l'appliquer aussi rapidement qu'en 2024
2025 il faut que ce soit signé vite là
mais le problème aussi qu'on a avec les
négociations actuellement c'est que le
gouvernement veut une convention
collective sur trois ans ce qui fait en
sorte que le temps qu'on négocie qu'on
le mette en place on se retrouve comme
tout de suite en négociation et les
syndicats de leur côté
que ce soit sur une durée de 5 ans mais
encore une fois j'en reviens à la à la
réforme de Christian Dubé puis il y aura
pas juste celle de Christian Dubé il va
probablement avoir une aussi de Bernard
brinville dans leur cas ça peut pas être
déconventions collective trop longue
s'ils veulent pouvoir appliquer les
changements nécessaires donc il y a
cette stratégie là aussi je pense que
les syndicats voient également qui ont
une bonne partie de bâton dans la grande
partie des chèques Michel C et Michel
David du de François Legault de son
gouvernement c'est négociation là sont
extrêmement importantes pour mettre la
souplesse dans les machines Michel cm
elle le sont toujours mais elles sont
plus importantes cette fois-ci parce que
la réforme de Monsieur duvet et parce
qu'il y a des pénuries de personnels qui
font que les conditions de travail dans
le secteur public sont difficiles Michel
le dit tout à l'heure il y avait raison
qu'en plus ils sont plus mal payés qu'à
peu près n'importe qui qui fait un
emploi similaire au Québec c'est vrai
mais il y a vraiment un côté je pense
que c'est un Picard qui disait des
travailleurs sont épuisés dans le
système et c'est vrai ça aussi alors ça
ça complique la situation
moi je suis pas sûr qu'on va régler ça
que le mois de juin
on serait surpris Michel David mais
voilà un dossier qui permettrait à
Monsieur le goût de changer d'air aussi
de la pièce un peu oui mais il faudrait
qu'il y a quelque chose de positif donc
ça tombe bien s'il fallait que ça
s'ajoute au reste ça serait plus
compliqué et puis même sur le goût dit
depuis arriver alors dans ce sens-là
maintenant on va faire valoir on a le on
a le son de la du groupe il est parti
allez-y Michel bon monsieur Lego répète
depuis deux ans là je pense que la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre c'est
formidable pour les travailleurs parce
qu'ils peuvent exiger ce qu'ils veulent
de leur employeur ben c'est exactement
ce que les syndiqués du secteur public
se disent la pénurie c'est le premier
employeur qui en souffre actuellement
c'est le gouvernement alors dans ce
sens-là ils ont quand même le gros bout
du bâton
Véronique a pu brève échéance demain ça
sera donc cette rencontre avec les
municipalités en fait les municipalités
qui se rencontrent alors il y aura
plusieurs fers au feu là pour le
gouvernement le goût monsieur Legault se
rend ABC Paul demain dans la journée
Véronique oui il sera baissé Paul pour
offrir son soutien même si c'est la
sécurité civile qui est en train de
prendre en charge toutes les opérations
dans ce cas-ci par contre avec l'Union
des municipalités ça va mettre la table
pour la négociation du prochain pack
fiscal ça c'est clair puis avec ce qui
s'est passé cette semaine
les municipalités ont quand même
beaucoup d'arguments en leur faveur donc
je pense pas que ça va être simple comme
discussion rien ne semble simple Michel
David vous aviez un papier assez dur
d'ailleurs ce matin pour le gouvernement
le goût pour le bureau rien ne semble
simple Michel David dans ce début de
deuxième mandat et rien n'est simple en
ce début de mandat parce que maintenant
il y a plus de pandémie qui permettait
presque de tout balayer en dessous du
tapis puis je blâme pas du gouvernement
il fallait absolument répondre à cette
urgence là mais pendant ce temps-là il y
a un paquet d'affaires qui ont attendu
et qui maintenant sont sur le bureau du
gouvernement et à particulier du Premier
ministre et d'ici la fin du mandat il va
être obligé de livrer Véronique
michel-cy merci beaucoup à très bientôt
au